-My first guest
is a three-time Emmy winner
starring on the very popular
series "The Blacklist."
Season eight
premieres tomorrow at 8:00 p.m.
right here on NBC.
I am thrilled he's here tonight
actually in the studio.
Please welcome James Spader!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Don't be a hater ♪
♪ It's time for James Spader ♪
♪ It's been a while,
you've been missed ♪
♪ You can thank me later ♪
♪ It's time for James Spader ♪
♪ Ain't that the dude
from "Blacklist"? ♪
♪ James Spader,
time for James Spader ♪
-Come on, James Spader!
Oh, my pal,
it's great to see you.
And, yes, thank you so much
for being here.
You look fantastic, by the way.
Thank you for dressing up.
You're wearing a suit.
You look great.
-You're looking...less so.
[ Laughter ]
-This is the --
I'm more casual.
-Remember when it was
only California?
-[ Laughing ]
No, it's everywhere now.
-You could wear your Crocs.
-I'm wearing, basically --
These are like --
These are Yeezys.
-This is my first time out
in eight months.
Truly.
-Wow!
I'm so happy that --
-You're my date night.
-Yes! I will be -- We are
your best date you ever --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They don't have the sake?
-Can we get a little sake
or something?
Is this -- I don't --
I couldn't even see you
if we did a Zoom interview.
-No, no, no, I couldn't --
This was the only option.
I don't know how the --
You know, I can't --
You know, I don't --
I've had a couple of times
over the last eight months of,
you know,
having to do, uh...something.
I just call in on the phone.
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
-I don't know
how to work any of the stuff.
I don't have a laptop or a --
-Yeah.
-I don't know
how to do any of it.
-Good, but that's you.
I would agree with that.
I'd say, "No, I don't..."
-And I also --
I'm not presentable at home.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-You know, I really --
Not really.
I-I-I'm...
[ Laughter ]
I'm either in the kitchen,
cooking...
-Yeah.
-...or -- If I'm in the house,
I'm either in the kitchen,
cooking, or in the bathroom...
-Mm-hmm, yes.
-Or...
[ Laughter ]
-Cooking.
-Or in bed.
-Cooking. There you go.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that's true.
So, yeah, don't --
My thing is that everyone wants
to do Zoom everything now.
So, whatever it is,
they go, "Zoom call?"
I go, "No,
you don't have to Zoom."
-Yeah, but I worry
that we've got to come back
from this at some point.
You know?
Like, I was watching
the beginning of the show
in the dressing room.
And, you know --
there are a lot
of people missing.
Not just audience.
But there are a lot of people
missing, in terms of...
-Yeah.
-...you know, the functioning
of the show and so on.
-Yes, yeah.
-And we can't let
the powers that be
think that this is
what it's gonna be
moving forward,
that it's gonna be, like --
You know, we don't want
to get them used to --
We don't want NBC to get used
to a skeleton crew.
-No, exactly right.
We got to get back.
Exactly right.
This helps us, you being here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I -- What would it be --
What was your life like
in quarantine?
-[ Laughing ]
-I'm trying to picture it.
-'Cause I -- you know, they had
asked at one point whether --
'Cause you and I
were supposed to do a show...
-That's right, in March.
-...when it got shut down, yeah.
And I think it was
a little later, maybe.
I can't remember.
But anyway, it didn't work out.
And I think that --
I think I got asked
at some point during lockdown,
or you were doing the show
from your home.
-Yep.
-And I think I got asked
whether I'd be interested
in doing it,
and I was like,
"You know, forget that."
-You can't do it, no.
-But I tuned in to see --
And, you know,
it was a Herculean effort.
I mean...
-Thank you.
-...it really, truly,
for everyone who, you know --
-I tried.
-I mean, really.
You know, and, uh...
I thought that was very
industrious and impressive.
You know, that slide?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. I have a slide.
-How did you do that?
-You have to have a slide
in your house.
Yeah, that's the one thing --
Yeah.
-That would not go well
with my hangover.
[ Laughter ]
-No, it makes it so much easier
to get to the kitchen, yeah.
To have breakfast,
you just slide down.
-Anyway, so you're doing that.
Other people --
Like, John Krasinski, like,
invented a network.
-Yeah, that's right,
that's right, he did, yeah.
-You know?
And I came back to work, like,
my first day back --
back at work,
Christine Bean --
great costume designer
we have on the show --
she conceived and grew
a whole human being
during this eight months.
I came in for my fitting,
and she was just, like,
heading out the door
to go have the baby.
And when we left in March,
she wasn't pregnant at all.
So, I mean,
what use of time is that?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-And then, my first day filming,
Megan Boone...
-Yeah.
-...who's on the show...
-Of course.
-I said, "So, how have you been?
What did you do
during the time off?"
She said, "I read all
of Shakespeare's tragedies."
-Wow.
And what was your answer?
What did you do
during quarantine?
-My youngest son,
my 12-year-old,
we'd go out
and line up beer cans
on the big rock out on
the far end of the garden
and shoot at them with BB guns.
[ Laughter ]
-So, someone had a baby.
[ Applause ]
Someone read all
of Shakespeare's tragedies.
And you shot beer cans
with a BB gun.
-And we'd throw the ball.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-You look great.
-Thank you.
-Yeah, Questlove looks great.
Yeah, thank you.
Also, I worked out a little bit
over the --
-You did?
[ Laughter ]
-More with James Spader
when we come back, everybody.